all of a sudden all the barriers to
adoption that the imprecise nature of
niche online groups had represented were
gone i guarantee that the content you're
consuming still fits more or less into
this mold and then all that changed on
march 10th 2008. drex here from poi
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow arts to benefit your
body and brain and today i'm talking
about a video that absolutely changed
the poi game and why and how that
happened before we dive in though i just
want to give a quick shout out to the
friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and ultra poi for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all of these amazing
businesses and what they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links that i have down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to non-business friends
of the channel johnny howard lane
machinski and becca beckham
thank you so very much for your support
for my work and my mission there's a few
moments that we can point to in the
history of poi spinning where everything
changed and one of them revolves around
what is probably still my favorite tech
poi video of all time the title of it is
poi transmission spinning in arizona and
it was released by zan moore back in
2008 i usually just refer to it as the
arizona transmission video and it was a
video that both started and defined an
era why was this video so influential
and how did it result in an explosion of
tech poi content and what impact did it
have on poi and flow arts culture both
for better and for worse
pull up a chair and let me tell you the
story of how the arizona transmission
video changed everything to start we
should probably talk about some context
for what the poi world looked like
before and leading up to its release
granted my knowledge of a lot of this is
spotty on account of i started spinning
sometime between the summers of 2006 and
2007 but this is the general impression
i have of what the scene was like then
poi and flow arts which was a term that
hadn't been coined yet were both fairly
decentralized there were no large
sharing platforms for people to exchange
information so if you learn poi it was
almost certainly in person from someone
else that already knew how to do it
there was at this point roughly a decade
during which an initial generation of
western poi spinners had been learning
and growing their version of the art in
relatively isolated communities across
the world the closest thing there was to
a centralized hub of information would
have been the home of poi website they'd
gone from simply supplying the props and
the materials to make them to hosting
tutorials and a message board that
attracted users from all over the world
those tutorials tended to be quite small
and quite short really just
demonstrations of different tricks
locked inside of a teeny tiny video
window that could sometimes be difficult
to make out
remember this was before video sharing
platforms were a thing so if you were
hosting videos it meant that you had a
file sitting on a server and you were
paying for the bandwidth of the people
downloading it and at this point tech
poi was kind of a niche element of poi
culture people would talk about it in
online groups and in very rare cases
make big posts with snippets of video to
assist in teaching the points i'm
looking at you right now sphericalist
manifesto but by and large these ideas
were kind of hard to communicate you had
to do it almost exclusively in text form
and video sharing was pretty rare and
hard to come by if you did shoot a video
it took an enormous investment of time
and energy and probably been tracking
down somebody with access to the right
technology to help you out if you did
make the investment in tracking down the
tools to make a video it was just as
likely that you were creating something
that was going to be distributed in a
physical format like a dvd
all of that investment time and energy
meant that you wanted to see a return on
it it was not common for people to have
access to video cameras and even less so
the resources to host videos so tech poi
had a number of limitations on how fast
and how far ideas could spread there
were a lot of attempts to describe
pretty intricate movements via text that
could be confusing or even misleading i
think it's safe to say that the
difficulties in acquiring broadcasting
and accessing information meant that for
many of the more complex ideas of tech
poi it was frequently difficult to get a
handle on them without crossing paths
with somebody in real life who
understood and could walk you through
them and then all that changed on march
10th 2008 that was the date that the
arizona transmission video dropped and
it quite literally changed everything
the two main stars of the video xan and
alien john had been in the poi scene for
years at that point and were well known
among the niche tech scene zan had
already released an instructional dvd
called the encyclopodia that functioned
to teach some of the more advanced
concepts in the poi world at the time of
its release he'd also started up a
youtube channel early in the platform's
history to which he uploaded a
performance video that for the better
part of a decade was the first result
you get if you search for poi on youtube
i cannot count the number of times i
watched freestyle fire poi and marveled
at the tricks on display in it even
inspiration for some more recent works
such as combining waist straps with
torsiontay jumps have come directly from
this video xanad also made a name for
himself street performing all over the
western hemisphere building up multiple
acts and learning a small mountain of
information about presentation and
capturing an audience's attention alien
john was an old-school raver and glow
stringer who'd cut his teeth performing
and selling poi at renaissance fairs
throughout the united states for years
while he didn't have access to a video
camera he did have access to a laptop
loaded with 3d modeling software and he
used his expertise in mathematics and
parameterization to simulate a variety
of different poi tricks based upon
content he'd seen posted in online
message boards as well as his own ideas
their paths crossed as they both
traveled through arizona and the two
decided to shoot a video along with
several other friends one day in papago
park both had spent enough time browsing
through online groups dedicated to more
advanced tricks that they knew there
were a whole host of ideas that people
had been describing but for which there
was no footage that was easily
accessible and the two resolved to
commit as many of these ideas that they
could perform to video as possible
during the process zam would function as
somewhat of a creative director
channeling his knowledge of composition
into setting up different shots and
would repeatedly urge alien john to
perform tricks that he thought would
look cool with trail visualizations on
them zan had been working on honing his
editing chops and asked john to work up
simulations for many of the tricks they
demonstrated dissolving between them to
showcase the ideas in action from what i
have gathered from interviewing each of
them individually on the project both
considered it more or less something to
hone their chops or something that was
just for fun neither one of them thought
that they were making one of the most
influential poi videos of all time to
understand why let's first talk about
some of the technology at play here this
wasn't a video that you bought on dvd it
was available to the entire world for
free on youtube it was far from the
first popular poi video to be released
on the platform nick woolsey at that
point had been uploading content for a
while but it was the first time that so
much effort had been expended on
something so cutting edge being released
for free secondly it wasn't just the
super advanced poi tricks in it that
people lost their minds over it was the
computer simulations that were being
used to demonstrate many of these topics
while alien john had uploaded a handful
of his computer simulations to his own
channel to show the possibilities of
what could happen with poi
they were again for a pretty niche
audience presenting them right alongside
actual human beings performing these
tricks gave the entire project a
professional and sci-fi sheen that was
absolutely groundbreaking and finally
this set the stage for poitek in ways i
think that none of the people involved
in making the video really anticipated
nor were they trying to do to give you a
clue how there's a really fascinating
post that john made about this video
when it was first released essentially
apologizing for it in some ways see
before this poi was still somewhat
three-dimensional you go back and look
at old circles of light submissions for
home of poi compilations and you'll
overwhelmingly see submissions from
people who are shooting poi with no kind
of preference for viewing angle weaves
really dominated this scene and they
look good from nearly any angle so
compositions could run the gamut when it
came to shooting video of people
performing them but in the arizona
transmission video overwhelmingly what's
being presented here is tricks that are
meant to be viewed from a comparatively
narrow angle with the performer's feet
planted firmly on the ground in a stance
that would come to mockingly be referred
to as a tech tree sure there were videos
in which people did 2d tricks as tech
trees before the arizona transmission
video came out but the arizona
transmission video made it look cool
instead of awkward john explained after
the video came out that many of the rock
formations they shot the video around
were in difficult to reach locations or
left the performer in a rather
precarious spot so they couldn't
actually move their feet a lot of the
time and an unanticipated result of this
was that it set a standard that has
lasted to the present day it helps that
video in its current form that is with a
camera sitting unmoving on a tripod is a
format that works really well for 2d
spinning
but this was the video that really set
that standard to give you some idea of
the influence of this video we get the
name of the trick zans diamond from
zan's demonstration of the concept in
the opening the irony being that zen
neither originated nor felt like he had
any claim to ownership over this trick
but the video was so overwhelmingly
popular that it effectively erased other
contributors to that trick who'd worked
on it previously as it happened the
technology for video cameras was rapidly
being democratized with a wave of
low-cost digital camcorders flooding the
market within a year or two of the
video's release
followed by the advent of increasingly
powerful cameras being integrated into
smartphones and it set the stage for an
entire generation of creators who copied
as many of the elements of the video as
they possibly could given the means that
they had at hand the ensuing three years
would see a dizzying array of other
videos released that were cast more or
less in the same mold as the arizona
transmission video
all would be posted to free streaming
platforms featuring artists
demonstrating one-off tricks of
incredible difficulty all while feet
planted directly beneath their shoulders
the format was frequently referred to as
tech blogs or research you'd see major
players dropping videos that were 6 to
10 minutes long that were compilations
of weeks if not months worth of poi
tricks that they'd banked up it wouldn't
be until the popularization of instagram
with its focus on one minute long videos
and immediacy that the power of this
format would be disrupted and begin to
fade away but there were some other
cultural changes that the video heralded
to both positive and negative impact the
practice of posting advanced poi tricks
online had a galvanizing impact on the
growth of the techpoi scene all of a
sudden all the barriers to adoption that
the imprecise nature of niche online
groups had represented were gone it's no
coincidence that the techpoi explosion
came as participation in many of these
forums including the home of poi forums
entered into a steep decline many over
the years have noted that this had the
effect of homogenizing poi in a way that
it never had been before
rather than having unique styles
centered around key players in
regionally specific locations ideas
could bounce back and forth between the
united states japan russia mexico and
everywhere in between
it meant that there came to be a roughly
accepted canon of what poi looked like
and the style that it represented but it
also meant that there were fewer truly
unique regional styles and it also
radically changed the demographics of
the poi world in the early 2000s poi in
the west was primarily practiced by
women with several standout men
practicing as well similar to what the
demographics are for hoop currently tech
poi on the whole had always been a niche
that was dominated by men with its
emphasis on competitive acquisition of
skills parameterization and emphasis on
individual tricks over gestalt flow it
appealed to young men wanting to prove
both their virtuosity and intellectual
bona fides the style of tech poi
depicted in the arizona transmission
video is one that's a perfect fit for
many young men
you earn respect by displaying your
virtuosity and it challenges you to
explore the limits of your capabilities
all while not requiring you to move in
any way that's seen as overtly feminine
there's some irony in the fact that xan
an accomplished dancer spend so much of
this video locked in a tech tree stance
with the ensuing explosion of both
supply and demand for tech poi content
young men flocked to the poi world and
flipped it from an art primarily
practiced by women into one primarily
practiced by men
and this unfortunately led to years of
misogyny expressed both overtly and
covertly within the poi world that i'd
argue continues to be a problem to the
present day now please note i don't
think that either zen or alien john
intended to contribute to these changes
or in any way condone these actions but
i also think that this video had a hand
in catalyzing that demographic shift and
regardless of where you consume your poi
content now i guarantee that the content
you're consuming still fits more or less
into this mold videos shared on a free
platform dedicated to showing off one or
more individual tricks and for my money
we can trace it all back to this one
video that dropped back in 2008 and the
resulting movement that it helped to
stoke what do you think about the
arizona transmission video do you think
it's as important as i've outlined here
do you remember the first time you
watched it what was your reaction then
what's your reaction now
[Music]
if you got anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to keep the conversation
going and to help my channel grow this
video would not be possible if it were
not for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
support
now do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions vlogs reviews combos and
more i'm on a mission to bring poi
spinning and flow arts to the wider
world and help people connect with their
brains and their bodies so help me do it
head on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you're
watching on youtube there you can get
access to a whole host of rewards and
help me along in my mission do check
that out please and thank you do you
like it when i do videos on poi culture
or history would you like to see more of
them leave me a comment and let me know
i can think of a couple other major
inflection points in poi history that
i'd love to cover if y'all would like to
see more of them i'll leave a link to
some other videos i've done on poi
culture down in the description or up on
screen if you're watching on youtube
make sure to get out and get your flow
on today and i will see you with a new
video on wednesday
peace